how do these policies stack up against
the other big tech companies so Alex
what Netflix is doing is by far as I can
tell the most generous policy parental
leave policy in the country 52 weeks
paid for moms and dads it starts
immediately you don't have to take
disability which means you can still
remain connected to work if you want to
you can break up the leave take a little
bit now go back to work take more leave
later and just today now microsoft also
updating its policy not nearly as
generous giving moms and dads though 12
weeks of pay leaves moms get up to 20
weeks of paid leave but still a huge
step in the right direction obviously
Alex this has been a major topic of
discussion keeping women in the
technology industry this is still a
mostly white a mostly male industry and
there's a lot of concern about women
especially moms leaving early at
Facebook you get about four months for
moms and dads pay leave you also get
four thousand dollars in baby cash
google you get 12 weeks paid for moms
and dads moms actually get up to 18
weeks paid so there's still a bit of a
difference at some companies in terms of
what what women and men get but you're
certainly seeing a number of these
companies taking big steps toward more
equity in these parental leave policies
which which is a huge a huge thing when
you talk about recruiting and
competition for talent right now is my
first thought Emily when I saw these
headlines crossed yes they want to keep
more women but also is this just how
does this demonstrate how competitive
the tech industry is when it comes to
talent I mean Alex this is from for me
as a mom and I'm sure you as a new mom
this is something that would really move
the needle if I could take a year off
every time I had a child to spend with
that child um yes I think this is
something that employees are
increasingly thinking about and could
certainly move the needle for someone
deciding between one company and another
I recently sat down with Sheryl Sandberg
and Richard Branson to talk about these
work family issues and and one of the
interesting things that they disagreed
on Sheryl Sandberg said look we know
that we're Facebook not every company
can afford to make leave policies this
Jenner
and Brent brenson actually disagreed and
thinks companies can do more take a
listen to that conversation not every
workplace can be as flexible as the kind
of flexibility i think virgin or
facebook could offer and we sit here
knowing that but a lot of them not sure
I'm not sure you write really what sure
so what should those companies do I
think most companies I mean there are
some there is some you know like if
you're you know say if you're flying for
an airline you better have to you know
check in at certain time and check out
at certain time all else that the plane
doesn't fly but i think you know most of
the head office type of jobs around the
world they can offer you know complete
flexibility and Branson is starting to
put his money where his mouth is at
virgin management which is a which is
small part of Virgin Group you do get 50
to wait to 52 weeks of parental leave
paid shared between moms and dads and
virgin says they're trying to do that at
all virgins companies around the world
one of the interesting things out of
Facebook and this is something that
Sheryl Sandberg specifically has pushed
is the importance of giving moms and
dads the same amount of leave her big
thing is that if you give more leave to
moms then that you know sort of
reinforces this idea that women are the
primary caregiver and that dads
shouldn't be taking as much time off as
moms and that the most important thing
is that that men and women get equal
time off it can be a little tricky
though because you know sometimes
employees when they get unlimited leave
ultimately take less leave so it'll be
interesting to see how this netflix
policy plays out